i think many of you are going to uh
enjoy this one even if it is horrifying
so
a few weeks ago sean hannity hosted
donald trump
in a a big town hall they made a big
deal out of it
people in the crowd were allowed to ask
questions it was set up as a complete
softball just to make donald trump look
good
and he looked terrible the questions
were super
simple questions we covered this and it
was notable because
even easy questions trump failed on he
was asked questions like
what were your biggest accomplishments
in your first term
what is on your priority list for your
second term
and trump failed on every single one of
these softball questions now just as a
reminder
here is trump asked what are your top
second term priorities
he couldn't name anything this was a
couple weeks ago
if you hear in 131 days from now at some
point in the night or
early morning we can now project donald
j
trump has been re-elected the 45th
president of the united states let's
talk how do
what's at stake in this election as you
compare and contrast
and what is what are your top priority
items for a second term
well one of the things that will be
really great you know the word
experience is still good i always say
talent is more
important than experience i've always
said that but the word experience
is a very important word it's a very
important meaning
i never did this before i never slept
over in washington i was in washington i
think 17 times all of a sudden i'm
president of the united states you know
the story of riding down
pennsylvania avenue with our first lady
and i say this is great
but i didn't know very many people in
washington it wasn't my thing i was from
manhattan from new york
now i know everybody and i have great
people in the administration
you make some mistakes like you know an
idiot like bolton all you want to do is
drop bombs on everybody you don't have
to drop bombs on everybody you don't
have to kill people
sometimes if john bolton in fact
released classified material
should he be prosecuted yeah oh
absolutely well he did release
classified
well trump was given another chance
in another softball sean hannity
interview a few days ago
and he was asked the same question and
he had
weeks to prepare a better answer and
he still failed trump was told by
hannity during the interview you know a
lot of people didn't like your answer
last time
what are your second term priorities and
trump goes on for two minutes
and says almost nothing again he got the
test
again he already had the test questions
he answered one way
he gets the same test again and he fails
take a look
let's what is your second term agenda
well first of all i didn't know i was
criticized for that answer because it's
a simple question first of all we're
going to defeat
the the invisible enemy and that's that
we're welded our way
and as again i told you the mortality
rate is uh
tenfold down we're going to rebuild the
economy we're going to bring back jobs
from all of these foreign lands that
have stolen our jobs on horrible trade
deals
we're going to continue to make great
trade deals we're going to finish
uh rebuilding our wall we're going to
finish we're going to have that it's
going to be almost complete by the end
of this year shortly thereafter it's
finished
it's made a tremendous difference you
see we're doing record
numbers on the border very few people
are able to get through
we're rebuilding with our military we've
rebuilt the military
2.5 trillion dollars we're fixing up
the va for our vets what the job we've
done there
between choice and accountability we
have choice where they have
with they can go out and get a doctor if
they're sick they don't have to wait for
five weeks six weeks two weeks uh so
we're doing great with the vets and the
vets are
loving trump we're protecting our second
amendment so
important we need more judges and more
justices you see that now with the
supreme court more than ever
and the next president i've had too and
the next president is going to be able
to pick two or three or one or whatever
but a lot of justices
and that means everything whether it's
for life or
other things i mean it means so much but
protecting the second
amendment getting more judges all of the
things that we've done nobody has done
what this administration has done in the
first three and a half years nobody's
even come close
when you look at everything that we're
doing now what we're doing is working on
lowering drug prices
and knocking out special interest
because it's not easy
we're fighting for choice we did it for
the veterans now we're doing it for
school too
we're one choice in school so a parent
can take their
child to a school of their choice and
that's happening very good
very very well and we have many things
that we're doing
and many things that we've already
completed and
you can't do more than what we've done i
think we've set records on every we
actually set a record on judges we're
going to be by the time of the
end of this year we'll be up to almost
300
so go through the list of what trump
said he says my priority is to defeat
coronavirus we've had one of the worst
responses in the world and when it's
defeated ultimately it'll have nothing
to do with donald trump
it'll be because of medical science he
says he's going to rebuild the economy
it's vague and meaningless that's a
vegan meaningless promise he says he's
going to bring
jobs back from places that stole them i
thought he already dealt with
fixing trade with his tariffs and usmca
he's saying oh so he hasn't actually
done that says he's going to build the
wall and that it'll be almost complete
within the year that's a lie and
remember he promised to build
the full u.s mexico border wall during
the first term
obviously it's not going to happen
obviously it wouldn't happen during a
second term
he again brings up we're going to
rebuild the military the military is
huge the military is fine the military
was fine under barack obama
there's no problem with the military he
again says
he's going to keep fixing the va for
veterans like with veterans choice
that was an obama uh provision that's an
obama program from 2014 which trump is
taking credit for
but he said that he did that in the
first term isn't it aren't we done
doing that so that's incoherent says
he's going to protect guns he mentions
that twice
he's done nothing as far as that goes
says he's going to lower drug prices and
kick out the special interest
that sounds great the problem is he
promised that for term one
and did the opposite he says school
choice
that's terrible in its code for take
funding away from
from public education and then again he
mentions judges three times now
that's a reason to remove trump and to
take control of the senate back from
republicans
but getting judges confirmed the senate
does that it's mitch mcconnell who did
that
no matter which uh republican president
you had as vacancies come up they
nominate people
it's up to the senate to go ahead and
confirm them so
if your second term agenda is the same
vague stuff as what you did in the first
term or
claimed you were going to do but failed
why do you deserve a second term it's
another one of these vapid word salads
and i
i actually listen i i worry i know
that part of the problem is that a lot
of voters hear that two minute clip
and they think trump outlined an agenda
like this is an educational problem an
agenda would be trump saying or you know
a candidate saying
i have detailed proposals on my website
but to sum up
some of my main priorities for the
second term are in the next four years i
want to
establish a public health care option
and drop the medicare age to 55
i will be establishing three new tax
brackets at 42 45 and 48
the money which uh comes from that will
be used to do green
infrastructure spending the details of
which i specifically outline on my
website in a proposal
but it includes retrofitting all
government buildings to certain
standards
it includes increasing the number of the
percentage of uh
you know energy that we use to be
generated from
these three renewable sources whatever
right will put us back in paris climate
and the who
that's something that sounds like an
agenda what trump said is not
anything and one of the real problems is
i i don't want to say people are stupid
but there's a lot of stupid people and
when i did
a segment just saying we've got to
realize a lot of people are stupid
many people don't realize that trump
didn't even outline an agenda like that
the problem is a lot of folks are
evaluating what trump said
to say do i like this agenda or don't
don't i like it he didn't
outline an agenda and a lot of trump's
followers don't realize that it's an
educational issue
at its core if you are anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into a doctor's office
right now and thankfully
there's a practical and affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that your doctor is
available to you anytime by text
phone or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video